need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you as well you've got Michael Jordan
level talent at something so get ready
to be joyful be sensitive to life and be
a visionary with sadguru and my take on
his top 10 rules of success volume 6 to
give you the motivation confidence and
belief that you need joy okay let's kick
it off with rule number one be joyful
only when you're in a pleasant state of
experience your body and your brain
works at its best there's no argument
about them there's enough evidence to
show that
so whatever impact or success or
reaching goals or growth or whatever you
say on one level in the physical world
it's about how well you harness your
physiological and your psychological
process isn't it whether your body and
mind works against you or works for you
this is a big difference so there is
enough evidence to show only when you're
in Pleasant levels of experience this
happens best so obviously Joy's fast
then growth if you are joyful constantly
and you have no fear of suffering
because you understand all human
experience comes from within you and so
you have managed to create the kind of
experience that you want now growth is
possible and riddled if you have the
fear of falling down and suffering you
will not go very high isn't it
rule number two be sensitive to life you
are a product of this planet yes or no
whatever nonsense the individuals may
think about themselves we are all at
just a pop up from this planet you seen
those pop-ups on the computer screen
pop pop yes you just a pop up you will
be gone you can't believe you will be
going on me I will be gone yes all the
very smart people countless number of
people who work this plan
before and you and me where the hell are
they are not a sign all became topsoil
isn't it so weren't they pop-ups and you
a pop-up poop poop you may think you
have a great life and this and that as
far as the earth is concerned it's just
recycling its soil
yes throws you up and draws you back
throws you up and draws you back so in
this little pop up the important thing
and the most important thing is you
create sensitivity within you such
sensitivity that every dimension of life
comes into your experience before you
fall dead is it not important you
experience this life in this fullest
possible scale yes or no experience
means people think we must party every
day no no same damn thing how many times
you will do there is much more for the
human life to explore you must become
sensitive when I say sensitive because
the word sensitive is used in the wrong
way in the sense when people say oh she
is very sensitive we are supposed to
understand she will get hurt for just
about anything yes
no being sensitive to life and being ego
sensitive or to different things being
sensitive to life means if you walk into
this hall you experience everything
that's here you don't miss a thing
if you walk outside you don't miss a
thing every dimension of life should
come into your experience rule number
three be a visionary what a vision
vision means is say everybody has
desires desire is an incremental way of
enhancing our life today you desire I
must have a home tomorrow your desire I
must have this money tomorrow you desire
something else
these are incremental ways of arranging
and rearranging our lives which are
needed to do a few things when you say
I'm a visionary what you're saying is I
have a larger desire which is not about
just incremental improvement of
my life desire is about me always vision
is an all in all inclusive process so
this itself is a phenomenal thing if
people instead of having desires if they
have a vision vision is always
all-inclusive desire is personal desire
leads to incremental changes and
improvements vision can transform the
whole situation rule number four take
control of your life so it's very
important that there is nothing to miss
out in life life is happening to all of
us question is only if I miss this party
I am I missing out something if I miss
this examination I am missing out
something if I miss this job am I
missing out something this is simply
because right now who you are is not
internally managed it is externally
stimulated when you step out into the
world if you leave it to the people to
decide what happens within you they're
going to drive you crazy in no time here
it's all managed for you you are not
managing this it's managed for you what
should happen to you what should not
happen till somebody else is managing it
when you step out on the street if you
leave it to other people's hands that
they can decide whether you're happy or
unhappy you're going to be miserable for
sure because they want to do many things
what happens within you must be
determined by you isn't it also if you
want to learn to have more self love
check out my 254 series it's free the
link to join is in the description below
the quality of your life is essentially
determined by how you carried this one
so rule number five think consciously
know technology is harmful it is just
that
when human mind is in a certain level of
destructive mode every technology is
harmful everything you can take your
laptop and slit somebody's head does it
mean to say computers are dangerous
suppose a few incidents happen like this
in many offices it happened let's say in
10 different offices it so happened
somebody took Apple air and slipped
somebody's hand does it mean to say
laptops are dangerous no human being so
stupid whatever comes their way they
know how to turn it against themselves
when they have turned their own brains
against themselves what else do you want
now there are technology d addiction
centers you know this like there are
drug dear addiction all call the
addiction now technology the addiction
centers simply because we are in a
compulsive mode if we start hitting we
don't know when to stop eating that's a
problem big problem quite a big problem
if we start drinking we don't know when
to start drinking stop drinking if we
start shopping we don't know when to
stop shopping if we start using the
phone we don't know when to stop using
the phone so the problem is not of
Technology
the problem is of compulsiveness when we
say compulsiveness
it's just absence of consciousness isn't
it if we were conscious human beings we
would use everything for our well-being
and everybody's well-being because we
compulsive
we start doing something we don't know
how to stop endlessly we will do the
same silly thing so whether it's virtual
reality or artificial intelligence or
anything of anything the problem is not
of Technology in ever because they have
just devices created by us we are
supposed to use it for our well-being
that's idea isn't it but see most of the
cutting edge technology always goes into
military usage in the world obviously we
don't know how to use it for a well
being we are always using it to destroy
something this has been the thing always
not just now because we've never worked
on human consciousness if human beings
lived consciously if the leadership in
the world was a conscious leadership a
question of using technology against
human well-being or the well-being of
anything wouldn't arise isn't it his
technology means enhancement of our
capability isn't it
rule number 6 manage your mind fear is
always about what may happen or may not
happen right fear is not about what is
what we are experiencing right now what
will happen is always the fear or in
other words your fear is about something
which is not yet your fear is about
something which does not exist
this is all management people if there
were a few somebody from a psychiatric
department you could have asked them if
I have fear about something that does
not exist what is my condition they
would have a title for you
yes romance is close by I think we can
always consult that is also a premier
institution we are suffering something
which doesn't even exist yes if you're
suffering something that doesn't even
exist it is not about life it is not
about education it's not about Korea it
is just about your mind being out of
control is that not an important aspect
that you should manage first before we
allow you to manage an industry or a
business is it not important first of
all you learn to at least manage your
mind hello isn't it important if you do
not know how to manage your mind what
the hell are you going to manage in the
world
managers are all freaking out in growing
ulcers in their stomachs yes today to
become normal if you are a CEO by 45 if
you don't have an ulcer you're not a
great CEO because you are managing by
accident like this the fear comes
because there is an accidental
possibility easily tell me let's say you
don't know how to ride a bicycle you set
on it it won't stand you are just
pedaling for fun
it came off stand and started rolling
anxiety or started rolling faster fear
or no very fast terror or no
it's not because bicycle produces terror
it is just that you don't know how to
ride if you know how to ride faster it
goes the better it is isn't it faster it
goes the better it is the very very I a
basis why we created a bicycle is
because we wanted to go faster than
walking the idea but if you do not know
how to ride how much fear it creates
right now your problem is not with the
world your problem is not with your
education your problem means your
education system right from kindergarten
hasn't told your damn thing about how to
manage yourself rule number seven
meditate people are having disturbed
sleep because of the way they're keeping
their minds if you are in a comfortable
state of mind if you go to sleep the
body knows when to wake up one day it
may sleep for this many hours another
day it may sleep for half the amount of
time it's perfectly fine body needs rest
body does not need sleep restfulness is
not in the hours it is in the drop of
metabolic activity that you have
generally in deep sleep your metabolism
drops approximately 8% you sit for
shambhavi
your metabolic activity can drop up to
24% the restfulness that you're gaining
in meditation is three times more
profound than sleep then one thing that
will happen to you is sleep water will
come down suddenly rule number eight
live a full-fledged life everybody is
looking for tidbits of life
give me three points with which I will
make my life one mantra with which
everything will be solved that's not how
life is it's a comprehensive process the
simple way to look at it is like this
today you know because of medical
sciences that your entire body in a way
is a chemical soup the question is only
is it a great super allows you soup so
if it's a great soup then it tastes
wonderful for you and tastes wonderful
for everybody around you if it's a lousy
soup then you have to manage with
presentation when the chef is bad you
know he decorates it these days food
comes with flowers on it
never ever
outside situations will happen hundred
percent your way but what happens within
you if it's happening hundred percent
your way you will be in the best
possible state always you will keep
yourself in the best possible way are
you as good as somebody that's not the
point
are you full-fledged that is the point
rule number nine master your inner self
if you go outside in the garden and try
to catch an end the bhu end
who is born here I was grown up here and
probably he'll die here
that'd be hu and if you try to catch him
he'll say okay to hell with my life okay
crush me if you want is it so he'll do
everything to protect himself he values
his life isn't it very much sure no tiny
little creature that we may not even
notice we may step on him without even
seeing him unfortunately but he values
his life immensely does he know he's got
spark but you a human being at least on
this planet you're the peak of evolution
physiologically at least yes if other
behavioral aspects if we may have
questions but physiologically at least
the most evolved creature on the planet
what the most evolved creature on the
planet means is it has the most complex
neurological system and it has the
highest level of cerebral capability
that means you can think you can
remember you have memory you have a very
vivid sense of memory and a fantastic
sense of imagination an ant doesn't have
such a vivid sense of memory nor does he
have any great imagination here's some
but he has a presence of mind about the
life that he is living because the
education systems that you're going
through right from kindergarten level is
such that it is about everything except
you it's about everything else
somebody is PhD in tourism somebody is
PhD in biotechnology somebody is PhD in
something nothing about this how does
this function there is no attention at
all
a human being functions you know you
have a car libido a temple here what
this means is a human being exists in
three times he lives because of the
richness of his memory how rich is your
memory determines what you will do and
what you will not do right now isn't it
so so memory is important the present
experience is important and how women is
your imagination for tomorrow is very
important right now the problem is these
things have all gotten mixed up because
discipline of faculty has simply not
come
nothing has been taught to our children
that there needs to be discipline means
people think English kind of discipline
walking like this like idiots discipline
of faculty is not there because of this
your own mind turns against you what
happened ten years ago you still suffer
hello what may happen day after tomorrow
you already suffer because there is no
discipline of faculty you don't know how
to use your memory you don't know how to
use your imagination your memory makes
you suffer your imagine makes
imagination makes you suffer and you
think you're suffering your life you are
not suffering your life you are only
suffering the two greatest faculties of
being human vivid sense of memory and a
fantastic sense of him imagination isn't
it so if you suffer the greatest
faculties that you have what can we do
with you if you suffer a ailment
understandable if you suffer a
disability understandable if you suffer
your ability hopeless case
yes or no you're suffering your
capabilities if you are suffering your
disability it's alright you are
suffering your capabilities I must tell
you this about four or five months ago I
think you might have seen it on the news
I am lately 34 year old lady who was a
television anchor in Hyderabad jumped
off the 5th floor window
kill herself left a note nobody is
responsible for my death my brain is my
enemy how many million years it took to
get this brain to this size and now it
becomes your enemy she articulated this
but this is true with almost 90% of the
human beings they are suffering their
own intelligence isn't it if you take
away half their brain if you take away
half their brain they will be peaceful
yes and that is why a whole bunch of
idiots are going about saying that the
ultimate goal of life is peace of mind
such people will only rest in peace and
you'll number 10 the last 24 very
special bonus clip is dance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now I have a special bonus clip from
Sadhguru on how to be 100 percent yes to
life but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what does living a full-fledged life
look like for you number two how can you
be more joyful today and number three
where do you need to take more control
in your life and if you liked this video
and you will take action after watching
it give me a hashtag believe down the
comments as well the difference between
heaven and hell is just this you are
doing something willingly
that's your heaven you are doing
something unwillingly that's your help
we have already taken on attitudes what
we like and what we don't like I like
this person I don't like this person now
with this person I will do things
willingly with this person I will do
things sunny unwillingly this may be two
people two aspects of life to
communities to nations to many things
this I will do willingly this I do
unwillingly this means I've decided in
my mind this is good this is bad when I
hear even on national news channels good
guys and bad guys it just once you have
this kind of thing you are going to be
disastrous to the planet it's just a
question of time the moment you decide
this is a good person this is a bad
person this is gone deep into American
society no there are no good people and
bad people
everybody is oscillating between the two
if you create a very pleasant wonderful
atmosphere everybody behaves wonderfully
if you create an unpleasant atmosphere a
whole lot of people act nasty yes or no
there are joyful people and miserable
people but there are no good people and
bad people
[Music]
the moment we think we are good we are
entitled to destroy the bad isn't it oh
we've been destroying a lot of people
for a long time time to stop that
because human beings are in different
levels of experience and understanding
variety of people anybody who's not like
you is obviously bad isn't it isn't it
so those who are not like me must be bad
people because the basis of goodness and
what you think is goodness is decided by
you now you have no business to do that
willing means this I'm just willing I'm
a hundred percent yes to life
I am NOT yes to this one no to this one
no I am just yes and yes to life if you
are a hundred percent a yes to life you
are a volunteer you have become a will
in life you have become so willing that
you have no will of your own
if you want more sadguru check out the
top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
always been people have been taught that
they must work hard nobody told them
they must work joyfully